at this army training center near Keith
Ukrainian soldiers run through combat
drills
[Applause]
they're practicing skills they'll need
when they are deployed to the front
lines
the instructor is 23 year old Deanna her
nickname is Sledgehammer
when I was growing up I didn't have any
thoughts about joining the Army but my
brother joined when Russia invaded I
couldn't stay aside and watch so I
joined too
there are 50 000 women in the Ukrainian
military of which 10 000 are on the
front lines
after Russia invaded Ukraine in February
there was an increase in women
volunteering to join the military like
Natalia sonenchko a 38 year old hospital
worker who on the first day of the war
signed up for the military when she was
told 90 percent of soldiers die in
combat from bleeding
she is now training in how to translate
her knowledge in first aid to the
battlefield her brother was killed by
Russian forces
I want to be on the front lines in the
war I want to help my fellow soldiers
because I want to win as soon as
possible to bring peace in Ukraine
unlike men women are not obliged to
register for mandatory military service
but that could be changing very soon
Ukraine is considering making military
service mandatory for women with
specific skills but said a decision
would not be made until next year
for now there are enough female
volunteers willing to join many like 25
year old Katya view it more than just a
job
I'm a patriot of my country I cannot sit
on my hands and do nothing in a country
fighting a war and training new soldiers
no matter what their gender Gabriel
zondo Al Jazeera Kiev